[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
Friday Friday Friday
made it Friday
Floridians trying to stay safe now South
Carolinians need to try to stay safe
is the administration
make sure that the the people that are
affected in the Hurricanes receive
relief
um as we'll we'll find out if the
governors are going to do what they're
supposed to do which is
uh again when I've been saying this this
is the third day now about Ron DeSantis
and I'm not going to stop either Ron
DeSantis is a piece of [ __ ] he's a piece
of trash
and he's just not gonna probably do the
right thing in the end I listened to a
little bit of his press conference this
morning he's doing the typical
walkthrough right
but um again no mention he mentioned
federal assistance
but no no mention of where and how
that's going to be done so uh Ron
DeSantis again
um is is in a bit of a quandary here he
has to sep accept federal assistance in
Florida
he has to he doesn't have a choice here
because of this natural disaster because
that's um how
and what government does
you got it you [ __ ] figured it out
yet
you know who's not libertarian you know
who drops the whole libertarian thing
the moment there's a national disaster
in their in their General vicinity no
one becomes libertarian anymore they
don't want to be liberated
from government funding anymore
from government interference they want a
lot of it
they become the opposite of libertarian
to be quite honest with you
and Ron DeSantis is going to show his
true colors here
and you can whatever you can say I'm
politicizing it but the [ __ ]
voted
voted as a congressperson not to give
Aid federal aid
to the victims of Hurricane Sandy in New
York jersey in New York
he was like no they don't get it
this is typical Republican [ __ ]
typical Republican manga Republican
trumpism republicanism [ __ ]
they're indecent
they have no empathy
they do not they they take all all the
humanity out of the American people all
of it suck it all out we see it we see
it on full display with these right-wing
talkers absolutely obsessed and pissed
that lizzo can play a flute
we played this video yesterday where she
was on stage
in the scandalous outfit I don't I don't
really understand what was so scandalous
about it
I mean she didn't have tits hanging out
I know what the hell they're so [ __ ]
scared of
they're terrified terrified terrified
that lizzo's legs are showing literally
that's what happened is that outfit that
lizzo has on her legs are showing
and they're just mortified
that a black woman a heavy black woman
who's very confident about her body
would show her legs how dare you you
people are [ __ ] stupid
this is how I know we've got them on the
Run folks do you think that this is
popular
do you think this is popular that
they're going to attack an artist like
lizzo because
she was playing a flute
with a leotard on what the [ __ ] are you
people talking about
just because lizzo isn't white blonde
and thin
because that's what it is it's [ __ ]
purebredded racism
pure blooded racism
full stop 100 now I asked the question
on my Twitter account earlier but I I
know that it's kind of rhetorical
I call them racist pieces of garbage
which Jenna Ellis clearly is so is Nick
Adams so is Matt wall so is Ben Shapiro
Charlie Kirk anyone else and I'm sure
Tucker Carlson's gonna chime in Sean
Hannity I'm sure all the [ __ ] racists
are gonna line up
to really get a good [ __ ] a good
[ __ ] go at it
on lizzo playing the James Madison's
flute
and they keep saying they're upset about
American history
right
that's what yeah it's a denigration
every American history what
that a black woman who in James Madison
had that flute mate would be a [ __ ]
slave are you even are you even
comprehending what you people are
[ __ ] saying before it pukes out of
your mouth
no they're not that's the answer
they're pissed off
that lizzo can play the flute and the
reason why they're the reason why it
seems that way
is because there's another video of
lizzo playing the flute in the Rotunda
and it's not just belting out a few
whistles
she's playing that [ __ ]
she's got more time she doesn't her main
Talent isn't even the flute
[Music]
it's not even the flute and she does the
flute better than they do anything
better than they overturn elections
better than they commit sedition better
than they get farted on by Rudy Giuliani
frankly
lizzo plays the flute better than all of
that
that's but truly truly what they're mad
about
is it's a black woman playing the flute
James Madison flute
the Founding Father the founding racist
he ain't come after me about calling
James Madison a racist I don't give a
[ __ ] come after me go for it
try it
look
this is typical republicanism this is
Michael Republican this is trumpism this
is fascism in a make America great again
again and again and again hat
that's what this is it's what it's going
to continue to be
and there's no reason to think different
or act differently you do not have to
guess how Despicable they are going to
be doubt me
doubt me
you don't have to guess you don't have
to sit and wonder oh maybe maybe this
time maybe this time Ron DeSantis won't
be a vile piece of gross [ __ ] oh maybe
this time no
no
believe them believe them when they're
telling you and they're showing you who
they are believe them
and it's all projection anyways every
[ __ ] bit of their of their nonsense
and their their grievances of the other
side is all projection all of it full
stop
because they have no arguments they have
no policy
their policy is to ban Book Fairs their
policy is to focus in on children's
gender and their genitalia that's their
policy you [ __ ] weirdos
you [ __ ] weirdos
they're always talking about our
children and save the children listen
stop talking about children's [ __ ] okay
stop talking about their genitalia stop
talking about their genders stop talking
about all that [ __ ] and focus on I don't
know [ __ ] that's like education and [ __ ]
make sure they have access
decent access to food while they're
[ __ ] learning
why they're reading books let's do that
let's get them to read books and do math
without having to bring in CRT
he's Banning math and Book Fairs in
Florida
and he can't stop thinking about their
genitalia and their gender either just
can't stop they're [ __ ] relentless
because it's all projection all of it
they don't have a real policy they don't
have they don't they don't have they
don't want to actually govern they want
to be a fascist State fascist states
don't govern what the [ __ ]
they're authoritarian you think
authoritarians govern well no
just look what's happening in Russia
today they're having to put on a big
show a big theater
about how Vladimir Putin is great at
government he's not
that they had a great election that's a
[ __ ] fraud and then you have Fox News
and Tucker Carlson simping for that
[ __ ] dictator
more theater they don't know how to do
it that's why they hate democracy
because democracy delivers equity and
equality
democracy's hard they're weak
they don't want to do the work and they
just want to oppress the rights of other
people they think they deserve and are
entitled to that freedom
that's what's at stake that's what
they're doing when you elect someone to
be the the
governor of a state like Florida who is
definitely 100 percent gonna have
natural disasters because it is in the
pathway of hurricanes it's not a matter
of if it's just when and how bad that
actual damage and that disaster will be
when you elect someone who who
absolutely strips
people of their Humanity
treats them like meat
but even years before that votes against
the same relief that he's going to seek
in that seat it disqualifies him
that alone
disqualifies him
you don't even have to get to the
[ __ ] high bar of the humanity with
these people and it's a high bar for
them humanity is a high bar for
Republicans holy [ __ ] it is just decency
and and humanity is just way up there
it's unreachable for them Jesus Christ
and we're all standing around wondering
how in the hell we're gonna prevent them
from taking the House of Representatives
get out and [ __ ] vote engage in your
democracy lean in that's what the [ __ ]
you do go check your registration today
make sure your friends and your family
are checking their registration
you want people like Rhonda santis
running running your state during a
national disaster trying to get federal
funds when he voted against them for
other people because they're just not
they're just not people he likes
now we have South Carolina the storm
bearing down on South Carolina
now it's not quite as severe
but it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
if it was a tornado in the midwest if it
was an earthquake out west
if it was a drought or a wildfire
somewhere
if it was a flood
it doesn't matter we're all [ __ ]
Americans that's the whole point of
democracy is We're In It Together
We're In It Together We don't have to
abandon people just because they have a
simple disbelief they have the liberty
of having that belief
just like you should and everyone else
should have the Liberty
but the reason why these Republicans get
caught up in these times of Crisis is
because they don't
they don't believe everyone should have
the same Liberty
they literally believe that their
freedom is to oppress the rights of
other people and they have that
entitlement
that's what they believe that's his
Christian nationalism [ __ ] that's
why they go on and on and on about lizzo
playing the flute it sounds weird you're
like how does that have anything to do
with white Christian nationalism well
because they're racist
that's why they're [ __ ] racist
and you you don't have to look far of
how [ __ ] racist they are just go
listen to Herschel Walker talk to a
crowd listen to him simp for racist
white people it is [ __ ] gross I mean
it is [ __ ] gross and those people
love it
I don't know if he took like some kind
of like master class from Candace Owens
or some [ __ ] but it's [ __ ] gross just
go look at how racist the Republican
party is go go look at Herschel Walker
talking in front of a PO I mean it's
hard to understand it because he can't
[ __ ] hardly put two goddamn thoughts
together without his brain glitching
guy's got something going on I I you
know I mean I think it's probably CTE
you guys just hit too many times in the
[ __ ] Noggin
he's got his his wires aren't all there
it's not it's not happening up there
but the [ __ ] he says about white people
holy [ __ ]
it's some racist ass [ __ ] racist ass
[ __ ] and I cannot believe that he's
standing in front of a microphone saying
that garbage I can't believe it it's
almost unbelievable
again it's almost like he took a master
class from Candace Owens
or Charlie Kurt maybe Charlie Kirk gave
him some advice I mean I wouldn't be
surprised would you
but here we are
in this state of emergency
in Florida
and elections have consequences folks
they do elections have consequences
so Ron DeSantis is the governor he's the
one with the power he's the one that's
going to be able to allocate the federal
funds
and siphon These funds down through the
state and to his constituents
and he is definitely going to [ __ ] it up
because he that is who he is
he's not going to change you think he's
just going to change overnight
because Joe Biden gave him a bunch of
money because the federal government
handed over federal funds
to make sure to prop up our our one of
our states
our American citizens help them out
you think he's just gonna wow I ain't
[ __ ] well now now I'm not gonna be so
goddamn vile no
he's going to continue to be that way
100 percento
but that's what we're dealing with
all the while we got all kinds of news
rolling in today uh Jeannie Thomas we
showed the video yesterday of her
showing up
and um
the January 6 select hearing all right
uh that testimony excuse me she was she
was giving her side of the story and
then I
apparently when she comes out to ask her
the simple question if she believes the
election was still stolen she's like of
course I do what which
that's the reason why she couldn't do
this [ __ ] under oath is because they
don't actually believe this stuff
now I don't believe they believe this
[ __ ]
I believe it's this it's the same [ __ ]
that they have to do they can't abandon
their vile gross nonsense if they
abandon it then they're constituents
their voting block the Maga Republicans
the vashes out there
will turn on them
I mean Genie Thomas went in for a
microphone yesterday and said no it was
not stolen Joe Biden won it was a free
and fair election there was no funny
business
it would tear down the whole [ __ ]
thing
because she's the head queuing on her
she's the head Cuban on her
I mean she's not Q or like a leader of
the group but she was the she was the
message board
from Q Anon to Trump
she was texting Mark Meadows who is the
chief of staff
who's within farting distance of the
president of the United States almost
every moment of the day
trying to pump this Q Anon [ __ ] into the
the president's head and it was working
because he's still talking about [ __ ]
that she was texting Mark metals that is
absolutely batshit crazy crazy ass [ __ ]
so we have that piece of news another
piece of news in Trump World is this
[ __ ] judge
this judge Cannon you've seen this
she decided to overrule the special
Master what is the point really here
what's the point
what is the point
with this special master
if he's not gonna actually get to be the
special Master this is this just a delay
tactic oh no [ __ ] way surely not
of course it is
they're trying to delay this as long as
they can
because dude is [ __ ]
he is completely screwed here he this is
not gonna go well for him on this
documents front
and it is more obvious now now
everyone's freaking out I'm a God she
you know of course she's a bonehead and
she was on our bonehead of the weak Bowl
because it's Friday it's Friday and you
know what Friday is Friday's bonehead of
the week
where you vote you decide and we break
it down we're going to break down the
bone of the week in the second hour of
today's show as we do every single
Friday
but this special Master thing as much as
everyone wants to you know get their
undies in a bundle here it doesn't
[ __ ] matter it doesn't matter it
really doesn't matter and the reason why
is because as soon as this judge can and
gives the Department of Justice
something a decision to appeal on
they're going to appeal it to the 11th
circuit and the 11th circuit is already
proven that they know Canon is a [ __ ]
idiot and she doesn't know what the [ __ ]
she's doing here
and really if I was Judge Deary I would
tell them to go [ __ ] himself I'm done
yeah you might you can take your special
master and shove it up your ass then if
you're not gonna let me be the special
Master you can go kick rocks [ __ ] them
that's I mean if I was diary and I
wouldn't be surprised if he does that if
he hasn't already I haven't checked
there's so much [ __ ] going on holy [ __ ]
I watched the uh um
Putin signed his little his little fake
election thing today it's rep it's fake
referendum I watched that political
theater this morning live live I watched
it anyways
you got to keep up with this [ __ ] you
gotta know what the hell's going on in
the world that's why you come here every
single weekday Monday through Friday
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on
YouTube Twitter and twitch and
simulcasting to the face of books the
books of face they're not Banning those
books yet
if you're on Facebook you know we we uh
we stream to the minus touch Facebook
page but I also stream to my page so you
should go follow me on Facebook don't
forget to do that that way you can go
over there I I post a lot of memes and
stuff over there I don't know if you
guys like that stuff but at the Tony
Michaels on Facebook go follow us over
there
but there's a lot of stuff to keep up on
and that's why you should come here
every single weekday because we try to
break down all the trending stuff
and I hate to I'd hate to go back and
try to do more about this lizzo and the
flute thing but Jesus Christ this is
just honestly
this this flute thing this right-wing
talkers on the flute thing
is exactly how they're going to respond
to everything
full stop
imagine if these people had power again
they would be [ __ ] sanctioning lizzo
and trying to investigate her for crimes
because she played James because the the
Library of Congress let her play the
flute I mean they would be doing all
kinds of crazy [ __ ] folks all kinds of
crazy [ __ ] because they can't this is
three days three days they've been
talking about lizzo
playing a flute
and it's historic
that a that a black woman
would be the first to play James
Madison's flute
from like 1813 or some [ __ ]
that's historic and they're like oh it's
denigration of history no dummies it's a
part of history now you [ __ ] idiots
just like you people are losers is a
part of History you are and we got to
make more history here
in the neck in the next well we're now
we're down to 39 days I believe until
November 8th we got to make history in
November folks
we got to put it down in the history
books that these [ __ ] lost big
time they got mountains of votes piled
on top of them my Republicans gone see a
[ __ ] every last one of those candidates
Blake Masters mastriano Dr Oz JD Vance
Eric Schmidt Herschel Walker Marco Rubio
Ron DeSantis Greg Abbott Carey Lake
every [ __ ] one of them gone [ __ ] em
just pile them up with mountains of
votes and it's up to you you are the
only one that can do this and I know it
feels like good Jesus I'm only one vote
I'm only one ballot it doesn't matter
you can engage you can lean in
do what you do best if you text message
really good find a campaign to help
I I guarantee there's one out there if
you like making phone calls do that find
one they'll let you make phone calls you
don't have to live in the [ __ ] State
you can make phone calls
you can you can rabble Rouse I rabble
Rouse every single day that's my
contribution I'm a good rabble Rouser
I'm damn good at propaganda I'm damn
good at politicizing things and I'm damn
good at yelling screaming in front of a
microphone so I do it two hours every
damn day
for you to take just a bit maybe just a
smidge of that energy that cathartic
energy and go out and and lean in
and absolutely destroy republicanism
[ __ ] them it's enough of this nonsense
this fascist [ __ ] where they want to
Yammer on and on and on about lizzo
playing the flute
as if that's oh my God that's such a
pressing matter that she played the
flute
and her legs were showing can you
believe it all right what's happening to
our country what are you talking about
Jesus Christ have you ever seen do you
remember in the 90s there was a country
artist Shania Twain you remember Shania
Twain beautiful beautiful great great
artist she's one of the best one of the
best country artists of all time Shania
Twain
songwriter singer
one of the best
guarantee you they've never watched the
video where her legs are hanging out of
her outfit on a music video and they're
freaking wow where the where's the freak
out our country's going to hell in a
handbasket and that was [ __ ] 30 years
ago I'm not saying I don't like Shania
Twain and I don't like that video
fantastic artist but they don't freak
out about that I wonder why hmm wonder
why
wonder why that is most of them probably
don't even know that Shania Twain is
Canadian
they don't even know they have no clue
no [ __ ] idea because they're [ __ ]
brain dead they're [ __ ] dumb
their thoughts don't go any further than
Tucker Carlson's mouth and his [ __ ]
and Sean Hannity Newsmax and oan and
whatever the Q a on Facebook page says
you don't have to guess you know what
they're gonna do and you know what you
have to do to stop them
you can't let these [ __ ] Psychopaths
these lunatics these racist pieces of
[ __ ] take power they're going to take
your [ __ ] rights away from you it is
a thing they're going to do it's their
goal
it's their passion really
and they're Relentless they are not
going to stop like it's going to take us
15 20 years to kind of readjust here
probably and get the [ __ ] the racist
the Michael Republicans the Nazis the
vashes to kind of crawl back underneath
their rocks
and we'll have maybe some party that has
a thin veil version of fascism like we
had in the Republican party for decades
and decades
since the Civil Rights Movement
but right now that is not our situation
the fascists are at the front door the
America First Nazi party is ready to
they want to shut that they're literally
campaigning to shut down the government
divorce say down there in Georgia
Marjorie Taylor Green hoof foot green
divorce a green is uh she is campaigning
to shut down the government
Martin Matt gatz Lauren but all the
boneheads are are running around yeah
we're going to shut down the government
that has never worked for them ever
ever that has never worked for them
it's always had an opposite effect on
what the American people View
it's just nonsense
and the reason why is because we
we the people are the government
we collectively
us individuals our communities our
states
our road districts our water districts
our power grids all of it our internet
all of it is the government it all is
it's all that thing where you set policy
and do it well
it's a thing
and they're gonna shut it down
I'm gonna shut down your government get
the [ __ ] out of here that's their goal
well stop them that's all you got to do
and what you have to do is engage in
your democracy
participate lean into it
and how you can do that is one way
is seek out whatever talent you have
texting calling if you got change if you
got spare change a little bit of money
in the couch cushion these campaigns are
gonna need some money here this last
month oh buddy are they going to need
some money because it costs money to do
this stuff
it costs money to deploy these efforts
to win
it does
that's one thing that we have the
liberty of here is to have to put up
with capitalism so that's what we have
to do we don't have publicly funded
campaigns
and you're definitely not going to get
publicly funded campaigns or campaign
reform
if you put the fascist in charge they're
definitely not going to do that
so I implore you lean into your
democracy
support pro-democracy speech that's
another thing you can do you can you can
support our show we run off your support
you go to tonymichaels dot live slash
tip Tony Michaels dot live slash tip you
can leave a one-time tip or you can set
it up monthly because we run on your
support and it's not just monetary
we need your support everywhere so go
follow us on Twitter at Tony Michaels
pod also subscribe here on YouTube and I
want to thank you we have 10 000
subscribers as of yesterday on air we
had ten thousand so thank you so much to
the audience
for getting us to ten thousand we are in
full growth mode and I believe we are
gonna keep going and keep growing
because you are our fuel you are our
support and we run off of your support
you can also support us by going and
downloading every single episode on
Apple's Spotify Google your favorite
directory wherever you go
to listen to your podcast you can
download it there and please while
you're subscribing on that directory
leave us a review if you can that would
help us out
folks you are the best audience on Earth
the best
audience on Earth and I appreciate
everything that you do coming here every
single weekday
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on
YouTube Twitter and twitch even when
we're banned and then over on the books
of face that might as touch in my page I
think we're going to start streaming to
Discord I'm trying to figure it out
I'm really trying to figure out how to
stream to Discord how that works I I
don't know Discord very well we opened
up a Discord uh server so you can go
follow us over there if you guys uh if
you guys play around with Discord you
can follow us over there you got several
people that are active over there and
we're going to start streaming the show
in there too if you want to watch the
the show in there and so I just I was
messing with it last night but
oh some of this stuff it's a lot it's a
lot of places that you're going and
streaming and here and there and
and then I gotta run the whole show but
I I appreciate you guys sticking with us
every single weekday listening
downloading coming hearing hearing the
great stuff that we have the great
content that we have here at the Tony
Michaels podcast the world famous show
so stick around because we're gonna get
to the shitless Roundup and then to the
Bonet of the week where you vote you
decide we break it down don't go
anywhere
bonehead of the week is coming up at the
top of the hour stick around we'll be
right back
[Music]
Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a MAG Edition
I knew I had to give it a try Babel Maga
Edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon I was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the words that I'm struggling with I
chose Babel mag Edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now I can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new Mega skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
[Music]
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
some people over on Discord are saying
yes stream the Discord please
they're begging for it apparently
so maybe you should go over on Discord
if you are on there and get in the chat
there on Discord and and we can we can
try to stream over there and figure that
out I gotta figure out how to do that
maybe I should just go do some research
over the weekend and figure out how to
stream to Discord you know like the cool
thing about Discord and I'm not sure
exactly how it's done but I know it's
it's a possibility where we could
probably actually take um uh calls we
can take calls like you guys can call in
on Discord
it's almost like a walkie-talkie phone
type app where you can talk into it
so if you have a question we can bring
you up on the uh on the Discord and you
can ask it right here live on the show
as opposed in the live chat you can
actually talk you can talk to us I
believe so I think that's the case I'm
not sure
I I don't know I don't know there's
there's so many apps and so much
technology out there now that we we have
to we have to figure that out so but
anyways anyways back to back to our
business at hand here and we've got a
lot of news to get to today and I've got
some video that I want to show you here
um because we got to get to bonehead of
the week
so let's do this uh first off let me let
me say again I really appreciate you
guys getting us to 10 000 subscribers on
YouTube it means so much to us to hit
that Milestone I know the next one is 20
000 and we'll probably get there uh even
quicker than we ever dreamed of getting
to ten thousand and the next mark would
be a hundred and so on and so forth but
thank you so much for for getting us to
ten thousand sticking with us
um every single weekday we do this every
single day for two hours it's a lot of
content it's a lot of time and effort to
put into a show and the reason why we do
it is because of you we do it because of
you and we run on your support again so
if you want to give a tip
just go to Tony Michaels dot live slash
tip or you can just go to
tonymichaels.live it's right there on
the home page you can give a one-time
dip dollar two dollars five hours
whatever you want whatever you want you
can set it up monthly if you want to do
it that way
and so thank you to everyone who who
does support us not just monetarily but
they also the merch the merch's been
flying off the shelves we've got this
dark branded design that is going like
crazy right now store dot the Tony
michaels.com
store.thetonymichaels.com the link is
down in the description all these links
are down in the description of the
YouTube video
so go go check that out go check that
out there and the other one that's
flying off the shelf is Rhonda Santos
can go [ __ ] himself
of course how appropriate for this time
right now
store.the tonymichaels.com thank you for
all your support here on the Tony
Michaels podcast so let's do this
because we got we got bone end of the
week coming up at the top of the hour
Gabe Sanchez is going to join us in just
a few minutes
let's get to the shitless Roundup let's
surf some Tweety tweets and 20
20. let's surf the Tweety tweets trendy
Trends start the countdown
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the shitless Roundup
where we round up all the Tweety tweets
and the trendy trends
get to the news of the day boy do I have
a video to show you here of Nancy Pelosi
just absolutely dunking Kevin McCarthy
in the [ __ ] Trish
dunked him in the trash I'm not sure
exactly what the reporter asked but she
responds let's listen
respond to those kind of questions I
mean with all due respect all respect to
your question at the end but not to his
comments because I don't even know what
he's talking about I don't know if he
does but the fact is
ah there she says she don't even know
what if Kevin McCarthy knows what he's
talking about I don't know what he's
talking about I don't even know if he
knows what he's talking about holy [ __ ]
just totally dunks him in the [ __ ]
trash I'm not even sure what the
question was I'm sure it's about his his
uh his his plan that he has have you
guys noticed that this this plan went
away have you noticed this and this plan
is gone what Republicans they had a they
had a what they had a plan what plan
holy [ __ ]
you notice I played babble
the mega Edition
um and it's not quite a dating app it's
a language app but there's apparently a
new dating app
out there for for conservatives that's
how they bill it fascist it's fascist
and they did a little commercial
now when I watch this at first I almost
thought it was a parody I almost thought
I was sat there I'm not [ __ ] you
this commercial is
it's kind of funny actually it's kind of
funny
it it almost couldn't be more well
written if it were satire
but it's obvious in the commercial that
these are not real users of this new new
fascist app this this this Nazi Meetup
app or whatever the hell it's supposed
to be it is very obvious
that these people were paid to say this
stuff which I don't blame them I mean
you know if you're if you got it you got
to get the job done right
you got to make you gotta make some
change I don't blame them
yeah watch this and just let's let's
watch it's only a minute long it's
laughable though let's listen they date
[Music]
what are you looking for in a partner
they just have to be a conservative
I want a man who really loves his family
definitely someone whose faith is
important to them for me it's someone
who actually wants to meet my parents
why do you want to date a conservative
for me at least I know that we're going
to start off with some shared values
while the conservative men outdated at
least know how to treat me like a woman
in my personal experience conservative
guys have better manners I like that
they understand their role in the
relationship as a man
I just prefer my men to be masculine
and what's the biggest red flag when it
comes to dating a Democrat no Democrats
a Democrat can't be a Democrat a
Democrat that's easy a Democrat no
Democrats to know
find the right oh my God so it's called
the right stuff here that's what it's
called the rat stuff
whatever you do whatever you do do not
do not download this app and create a
bunch of fake profiles to make fun of
these people please do not do that that
is not a thing that you should do
it
probably it probably would be funny
hilarious
and to flood the app with a bunch of
fake accounts and really shitner cereal
does anyone really believe this [ __ ]
does anyone believe that any one of
these people in this in this uh this ad
believes anything they said other than
they believed that they were getting
paid to say it
well the best part is the best part is
is the laugh at the end watch this where
she laughs at the end they made it like
oh God oh God she's laughing she's
embarrassed that she even had to say
that script that's what that's why she's
laughing they thought they would cut
that out she really thought they would
cut that out
oh you gotta be [ __ ] [ __ ] me it's
called the right stuff though that's
literally what it's called The Right
Stuff
they're looking for manly masculine men
with manners let me ask you folks do you
think do you think that that you would
go find a great Ben Shapiro type on this
app that would be masculine and manly
with manners oh [ __ ] out of here
get the [ __ ] out of here come on a lot
of people don't want people with manners
in the first place they don't want
someone who's going to capitulate to
Nazis and have manners around Nazis [ __ ]
you now that's not what we want we want
people who are gonna [ __ ] saying to
say the [ __ ] that we need to say out
loud and sulfur here has the uh
has the right idea the white stuff yeah
seems like it seems like it so whatever
you do please don't just you know I know
you're getting these ideas in your head
like oh what could the the profile pic
be and the screen name just don't
don't go over there and create
a fake profile and flood the Zone with
this thing it's probably not a good idea
oh my God
I want it so go [ __ ] with these people
over there
and mess with them they've tried these
they've tried these manga dating things
several times
and I think isn't this um isn't this
Kaylee mcananey's
um Sisters app and this her app Gabe
Sanchez do you know is is this Kaylee
mcananey's uh sister's app is that is
that what this is this is the one so
this is a Peter teal supposedly he's
he's funded this the white stuff I mean
the the right stuff
the right white stuff right yeah but um
it I don't know I couldn't I sent this
to you this morning I'm like we couldn't
even write this any better they stole
this from us like we it's so sad because
I think you're working aren't you
working on something that's you know I
have a uh hold on that looks at my my
settings are blurry right now oh there
you are there oh I'm much better much
better there oh looky there get that
look at that handsome dude holy [ __ ]
okay so yes I am one I'm working on a uh
I write stuff commercial and two you
know what since we're on the topic let's
just play a video that I have oh great
did you load it in I'm I'm loading it in
as we speak that's good one moment uh oh
speaking of loading in is the uh b-o-t-w
okay okay it's right okay
b-o-t-w-e-o-tw bone it up the week
up and in okay good well easy there
fella easy there fella sorry huh easy
there fella
um so what's this video that we're gonna
watch here so this is actually
um so you know obviously with app
development there's a lot of
um
uh you know
prototypes you go through right to test
it out to make sure that this is
actually
uh working actually
um and so as you saw in that commercial
the video for the right stuff there's a
bunch of uh people giving testimonials
and this is when they were you know kind
of prototyping the idea of the right
stuff okay so they were working on the
scripts when they paid the actors
because this is clearly when you watch
that commercial
it's clearly a bunch of actors these
these are not these are not real
testimonials these people have not used
the app they have not dated anyone
inside this app because they're talking
about conservative men that are
masculine with manners and like really
have you have you like done any kind of
research on the internet about these
manga types I doubt manners is really um
no no because it's both it's both for
you know Republican men and women are
conservative men and women to find each
other
um it's interesting that they only bring
up the women in this uh right wasn't
only women in this example it was only
women it was only women in this
particular
this version actually is with only the
men oh so so you're saying you're saying
um the one that you have here is with
men only in this video Yep this is the
Mega Men version okay so so this would
be like the the opposite because there's
Gabe in this app I'm sure there's only
two genders in this that yeah probably
only two yeah well I think sure I think
that I honestly think in their first
promo video they said specifically that
they're like are you looking for places
that you only have to have one or like
you have to have two genders so it's
easy you don't have to play it as
pronoun game
if I remember correctly they definitely
did a dig at pronouns and gender when
they did the initial like hey check out
the right stuff I mean the whites I mean
the right stuff you know uh but yes
there will be an app called the white
stuff
um this is their promo for the right oh
stuff so in other words this this is a
competing app no no no this is oh this
is the same man okay this is the right
stuff it's it's in I loaded up into uh
okay I got it there let's play this and
see what what what uh
what we're looking at here
[Music]
Joseph will you be my 12 to 14 year old
Mary if you're one of those
over-educated and under love Millennial
women who own cats and microwave dinners
hit the fast forward button Honey hi my
name's Philip will you be my Earthen
vessel hobbies include book Banning and
ball tanning if a man meets a virgin who
was not betrothed and seizes her and
lies with her he was a minor mix-up I
was her groomer and a groom
a groom groomed to be gotta be white
Life's a classroom and I'm just looking
for someone to homeschool hi Mom I'm
celibate by choice of course no smokers
no dopers and definitely no wokers hi
I'm I'm looking for a producer of a
domestic supply of infants that I can
stockpile
early early prototype commercial you
know obviously just from the male
perspective because that's that's pretty
important in this day and age they're a
underrepresented marginalized community
that needs their voices to be heard ah
[ __ ]
oh boy I can't wait to see how popular
this this app of right stuff gets to be
you know they've tried this manga dating
app several times and it's never it's
never worth it I mean if I let me uh
because when I was when I was uh looking
for that video you know I tried it no
more on the deeper web right uh it looks
like you did it doesn't look like you
dressed up in several outfits in front
of a green screen and not a video not at
all that is not a thing that happened
did you post that on Twitter you should
put that somewhere yeah okay good I'm
gonna put it up there so uh there are
there was like more than 13 sites that I
think uh were
these conservative dating sites there's
13 of them well there were more at the
time
um they're not writer Patriot oh these
are just three like that I can find
right now uh um wait wait wait wait say
the names again
writer writer like right like all right
g h t r i g h d e r right turn it's a
like the right the right wing The Right
Stuff they're not very creative when it
comes down at all
is horrible to the actual name so but
yeah it's uh let's see there's writer
uh conservatives only of course right
um oh so is that like is that like is
that like a farmersonly.com yeah it's
kind of like that it's kind of like a
play on that yeah yeah okay um there's
also Donald daters
make America date again
that they gave it
can you imagine can you imagine actually
meeting up with these people
because I mean you got all the people
I mean it would be a good experiment
though right like yeah you know
atrio dropped the T
is for conservative patriotic singles
um see the thing is all of these apps
came in to play When Donald Trump was in
office especially when he first came
into office however
they quickly [ __ ] the bed because they
don't have a lot of people that were
joining I mean let's see patreon had uh
wait wait is it could it be and I'm just
snowballing here could it be that most
women don't like to be treated like
pieces of meat like these [ __ ] idiots
want to treat them and
and that it was only dude signing up on
these on these apps I mean I'm not
saying that's it but it could be that
like I'm sure I'm sure these women just
snowballs were like oh I'd love a
conservative man and then you know they
join all these apps right you know you
want to have options you want to see
what's out there you know you're on
Bumble you're on Tinder you're on
patreon you're on uh conservatives only
you're on Trump singles you're on Donald
dates like these are all these apps that
come out there so you know they join the
apps right and they want to see what are
the options and they go through and they
realize that all the same [ __ ] white
CIS dudes are on that app and like [ __ ]
I already think they all look like they
live in their mom's basement you think
that's oh 100 100
or or they look like something they're
not right or they're like you know
there's always like the what photos you
include I'm with the group of friends
I'm with the dog I'm with my nephew
slash niece you know you gotta show that
uh I've got a sensitive side but I could
be real tough like oh look I'm I'm doing
a a Donald Trump pose on a stump long
with a with a plaid shirt on kind of
look there's that one too like there's
all these things but I think when all
the women are joining them they do
realize [ __ ] well actually the actual
dating Pool isn't that big and it's not
that great all right oh man these are
these are the Trump supporters I've been
looking for is that probably what
they're thinking
you know the other thing too is I'm sure
it's a lot of fake faked up accounts
right because you see this a lot on
Twitter like they got they got these
accounts or you know these Trump trolls
these these [ __ ] Maga trolls where
they they get like they're it's not a
real account I mean like it's a person
you know being a troll but it it's all
faked up it's not real there's nothing
real behind the about the account you
know it's just some dude sitting in his
mom's basement or something who's right
got some grievances because he was
rejected by a bunch of women because
he's an [ __ ] I mean that's probably
I'm just I'm just snowballing here I
mean those are the facts those are the
facts those are speaking of facts okay I
don't mean to go another day where we're
talking about this [ __ ] flute thing
but Jesus Christ
they just can't quit on this flute thing
right now this is more green M Mr Potato
Head CRT they're taking your country
doctors all this it's the same [ __ ] and
if you think that you want to put these
people in charge who are absolutely
concerned with lizzo playing a flute
because her legs were showing you people
are dumb I want to show you another
video here Gabe though this video is of
lizzo playing the flute and she's
actually in the Rotunda
um I believe that's where this is and
um she because the video we watched
yesterday she just belts out a few
whistles right and I don't know if it's
called whistles and I might I I might
offend some flutist you call them
something different loudest they're
called flautas right the people who play
flutes they're flutists so
um here's the thing that she belts out a
few whistles here but this she is
playing a song here this is this shows
that she is super talented that she can
pick up a damn Crystal Flute from 1813
in that when it was from 1813. that's
right pick it up
whistle into that son of a [ __ ] and Bam
music comes out now I I'm pretty good at
at singing and I'm not very good at
instruments so I I don't have a talent
to like pick up and I mean I can make it
make a sound it just wouldn't sound
worth of [ __ ] you know what I mean like
someone asked me the other day there was
a piano or something like ah you should
play on it I'm like are you kidding me
that would not be a good idea I don't
know how to play the piano
that's exactly what a piano sounds like
right well that's what it would sound
like when I play it right right but
lizzo is talented enough that the flute
she plays it beautifully even a crystal
flew from 1813 and that's not even her
greatest Talent it really makes me think
that their beef here is that she's black
it really it really starts to get that
that feeling because when you watch this
video because they're talking about the
other video where she's wearing the
outfit where her legs are showing and
they they say she was twerking which I
don't think that is I don't know I don't
know really what twerking is but I don't
know but anyways her legs were showing
they were offended that her legs were
showing God forbid a woman did what she
wanted with her own body right God has a
choice God forbid her legs be showing
while she's playing triggering
a woman playing white man
's crowd who's
dude really upset but here she's not
do you think do you think that's like um
I wonder if on um The Right Stuff the
white stuff dating app if there should
be there should be more pronouns there
should be triggered there should be
Trump one I'm sure there's more than
just two pronouns we need to check into
that remember remember Ted Cruz said my
pronouns are uh kiss my ass what does
that even mean I don't know dude he
knows trying to be tough and like no Ted
Cruz is nothing but a cuck okay oh my
God have you seen the video of him on an
airplane and that guy cucking him while
he's trying to get his he's like fix
your [ __ ] duck oh yeah he's like dude
I know the names of the victims of
Vivaldi okay give me one yeah
I gotta go to Cancun here soon I gotta
go back the NRA just paid for a a little
little Beach vacation
uh so
um here in this video
lizzo belts out a [ __ ] tune out of
this crit again this is a crystal Flute
from 1813 folks she is the first
American to play this thing that's the
other thing that pisses him off that
it's not a white dude playing this thing
the version exactly well again like I
said yesterday these people did not know
this thing existed now the first time
they learned about it was when she got
it on stage and then they saw the video
online they're like whoa whoa whoa whoa
trigger good lips that should be on that
flute or a white man's lips that's what
they want that's what they want and
they're just so upset that they're like
oh we weren't even in viewing distance
of this thing in real life we now have
to find out that this thing exists and
it was I don't know if it was ever
really played before that uh since 1813
no I think I think that is the point
here the library at Congress wanted
someone to play this thing and they
found someone I don't know with Talent
crazy you know crazy who to thunk it uh
they found someone talent to play it
because they wanted they wanted to show
the world through content because the
way you show the world stuff now is
through social [ __ ] media there's no
[ __ ] newspapers
anymore until you know people want to
ban social media much like Republicans
are Banning books so that we remove
certain moments in facts from history
you would you are you saying that
Republicans might try to scrub these
images from the internet if they were to
take power okay let's watch this this is
a beautiful video by the way
um not only is she playing the flute but
she's in a fantastic rotunda here uh the
crowd is watching her everyone's taking
a video because it's mesmerizing this is
a little it's once in a lifetime moment
right this is a little different than
the video we watched yesterday because
she's not on stage in front of a crowd
right she's literally I mean that was
historic but this is even more historic
here because this is more of an intimate
moment and she actually gets to play
this thing
um not just not just for a crowd but she
gets to play it for herself in this Hall
to hear it which is I think kind of what
she's doing here and it's it's actually
beautiful so listen
[Music]
and there you have it how about that son
of a [ __ ] I mean God forbid a
classically trained black woman with
this amount of talent is able to play
this Crystal flute which I never even
knew you could make a flute all right
Crystal I had no idea well she makes the
joke she makes the joke on stages like
playing a wine glass right right exactly
which is hilarious which you know the
closest thing I can play to plane of
wine glasses the the water on the rim
going you know oh you can make it make
some noise
if you were in a beauty pageant would
that be yourself like you know like
Sandra Bullock and Miss Congeniality
She's playing all of them I'm not that
good but you know I can make him make
noise I can hold one frequency oh okay
so you're about as good on the wine
glasses I am on the piano yeah yeah yeah
and it's the piano
You Got It piano okay so so here we have
lizzo which I want to point out her legs
are not showing in this now our midriff
a little bit of champagne see you know
what they're really upset about I think
is that lizzo was at a concert and she's
a musician right and generally when
musicians have concerts like and I
pointed out Shania Twain is is uh a very
great artist I mean you could put lizzo
and imagine that that's a great idea
maybe I should pitch this to lizzo and
Shania Twain they should do a concert
together like they should do a concert
together that would be a [ __ ] banging
time but here's the thing Shania Twain
would wear outfits that looked like
lizos in the video in the 90s and
they're acting like that her outfit is
new and denigrating like what are you
talking about female female artists have
been wearing outfits like that for
decades do they remember Madonna in the
80s right come on give me a break I
don't see anyone complaining about if
there are men on stage dancing with
little to no clothing or taking their
clothes off right during a show runs
around with his shirt off
runs around the shirt up but here in
this moment because this is an intimate
moment with lizzo and the flute right
this is this is I I actually like this
video way better than the other one
because it really it really show it
shows off her Talent here
um and and again for them to [ __ ] about
this one like she's dressed in street
clothes like this is if you were to run
into lizzo into in a grocery store this
is what you get and she'd probably be
nice as [ __ ] to you she wouldn't be a
bastard like the people who sign up on
the right stuff
um you know have no manners but here
here uh this is this is the piece of
content that I wanted to show you this
video but Jenna Ellis you know all the
dudes all the white right white wing
white right wing right I keep saying I
keep getting right and white mixed
around today I mean are they any
different I don't know and um it's
beginning to get to one but there is
there is uh there is something in in my
mind that you know that I think about
here is like I guarantee like if there
was you know how they do like the Pepsi
taste test challenge right they're like
yeah is that Pepsi what is it right they
got like Coke and Pepsi in a glass and
they're unmarked right right exactly and
you gotta guess which ones which if they
were like Hey we're gonna play you two
songs on the flute
blindfolded you're gonna tell us you
know what you think right yeah and
they're like oh man they both sound
beautiful they're sound great and
they're like all right this is this
white person and this is lizzo or or
they give it back they're like this
artist is classically trained she's done
this many years she's toured this many
places and they're like oh my God who is
it like you have an image in your mind
it sounds like it's fantastic lizzo and
it's one of those things can you imagine
the triggered that what happened I mean
imagine anyone in in in the area that
she was playing that song that were like
oh man that's really nice like a
republican like lawmaker was like oh
that's really nice and like walking
through and like oh my God and they'd be
like free
well you know this is the thing like no
one's no one would see this coming that
they would freak out over this like
that's why I mean that's that's the
mentality that Americans have that's the
same green imminent and Mr Potato Head
the same [ __ ] the same [ __ ] [ __ ] the
same nonsense right
and the dudes I mean it's it's almost
like it's their job to do this stuff the
the Ben Shapiro's the Matt Walsh's
Tucker you got to be outrageous
especially when it's got a vagina
involved and when it's a black vagina
holy [ __ ] lose their minds they're
triggered
but in this video it is uh the Fart
Catcher
yeah that is true because he farted on
her and gave her good right yeah that's
where because I have the nickname
Grandpa farty mcsharty which is that's
what I call Rudy Giuliani that's where
it came from that video that little
video where he farts on her right right
that's where I got the nickname
yeah well and he farts way into the mic
like yeah he even kind of somehow
somehow he you know how you know how
like ventriloquist can like throw their
voice right he's able to just like throw
his fart I know somehow he threw the
fart to the mic and everyone heard and
Jen house was like
what I find really stunning here in this
video is how Jenna Ellis goes after
lizzo's size I'm like are you [ __ ]
kidding me I mean this is this is crazy
that you know and I I've talked to a lot
of different women about this and asked
him about this and they've told me that
women are vicious and generally speaking
women hate women more than men hate
women like this is a thing and that of
course I'm not one so I don't know and I
don't know if this is some of this but
really honestly Gabe this smells of
racism
really bad like the it's got that that
stench so that's why I have not heard a
single valid reason why lizzo should not
be able to play that flute well I mean
obviously she knows how to play it right
I mean she's talented enough to pick it
up and play it I I mean Jesus Christ I
shouldn't even be allowed to touch a
crystal Flute from 1813 let alone yeah
put my lips to it and blow into it like
I'm gonna [ __ ] make it make sound or
some [ __ ] but now do you have her she
can I don't know it could also be some
sort of Freudian like phallic kind of uh
thing where they're like oh a flute oh
you know and I don't know oh so you
think these guys are like like flutes
oink like is that what you're thinking I
mean you know I'll tell you what this
this face here that I gotta buzzed on
this looks like the fart face this looks
oh
this looks like the you farted on me
face right it definitely looks like that
okay let's
let's watch
Jenna Ellis embarrass herself because it
is embarrassing and in in just the last
few minutes that I have with you uh Ryan
I wanted to turn to this you
just eat your pop culture story about
lizzo and this is just I think a
beautiful example
and a perfect example um it's actually
you know hideous but I say it's
beautiful in a rhetorical sense because
um of pop culture and just where the
left is looking to shape and move our
country so what happened if you haven't
watched the video
um do so at your own okay first off
lizzo it's not the left pushing lizzo
lizzo is one of the most talented
artists in this [ __ ] country not only
is she a talented musician and dancer
and of of loudest as Gabe says am I
getting it right there
a brilliant loudest she is she is a
tremendous actor as well
she she is so [ __ ] talented
and just because she's a a heavy black
woman that disqualifies her from being
part of popcorn get the [ __ ] out of here
with that [ __ ] this this idea that
lizzo does not get to be part of Pop
Culture because she's Talent is just
absolutely [ __ ] ridiculous what is
this the 1930s 40s and 50s where white
people steal black people music as if
it's their own and crowd around on
records and appropriate their culture
and their [ __ ] music and sell it as
rock and roll white people rock and roll
get the [ __ ] out of here with this old
ass [ __ ] that's exactly what she's
doing here is saying the left is somehow
pushing lizzo on people no bonehead no
one no also I want to point out that no
one brought this up she played it and
everyone's like holy [ __ ] she played a
crystal flute that's crazy right and
it's like also people being like holy
[ __ ] we didn't know that thing existed
but the only people that are pushing it
are the right because they're upset as
we see from Matt Walsh Ben Shapiro you
know Jenna Ellis like all these people
are incredibly upset and triggered
that she was able to do this right she
got this opportunity to play this flute
in front of other people that they
didn't know existed or they weren't able
to see or touch or whatever it is I
don't [ __ ] know but it's their it's
their jealousy their Envy whatever you
want to call it that a talented black
woman was able to use her talent to play
this this musical instrument and that is
the only thing that's being pushed right
now by them by saying like oh how dare
they do this how to no one else no one
else is pushing as hard as people like
uh those on the right and and when I say
pushing it I mean maliciously pushing
right not like oh my God this is amazing
they're saying oh my God this is such a
stain on earth oh she goes a lot further
here in this video she goes a lot
further in this in this video but it
really is it's it's just weird to me
that that the Library of Congress
approaches lizzo because they want
people to know about this Flute from
1813 which is a part of American history
it's really [ __ ] cool and they
thought what better way than to get one
of the most talented artists in this
country to play this [ __ ] thing and
play it well and do some [ __ ] social
media videos so people know this thing
exists so people I don't know think
libraries aren't a bad thing yeah
because this is held at the Library of
Congress
it's just it's [ __ ] I I just well
let's just listen to the bonehead here
own risk because you know so is
basically
basically I have to I I can't even I
mean what three seconds I I played into
this thing again why is that even
relevant well I mean I think she's she's
referring to the fact that lizzo is very
confident with her heavy set frame
but she's not famous for being morally
obese she's famous because she's one of
the greatest artists on Earth right now
like that is the fact and that's really
what pisses him off that's also just
that kid rock isn't you know selling the
records at lizzo is right exactly but
this is also the same type of stuff that
you hear from them whenever you try to
present an argument or like hey let's
have a debate let's present the facts as
soon as you debunk anything it it
directly becomes this personal attack
and this is an example she doesn't have
anything to critique about lizzo because
she was able to play the flute and do it
well so the only thing that you can do
is attack her personally and it's this
moment of fat shaming which is like that
is not okay that's not something we do
that's something you just keep to
yourself and whether you have your own
insecurities because you're not as
talented and you don't have as much
attention and you've got this show that
Arizona I don't even know where the
giant is I don't know but it's one of
those things
Network or something fat shaming and
attacking someone on a personal level
like in a malicious negative way you're
not doing yourself any good because
you're making yourself look even more
like a [ __ ] and an [ __ ] you know
the best part about this whole thing
is Jenna Ellis and any Maga Republican
anywhere even even the the Maga King
himself couldn't sell out an arena like
lizzo could no I mean not even if we're
going on crowd size here you [ __ ]
boneheads are gonna lose every single
day of the week with crowd size with
lizzo like you people really and that's
what I I I wrote the question this
morning on this video I was like why do
they think this is going to be a popular
stance like how do they think that this
is going to build a constituency
around attacking lizzo I mean it would
be one thing if it was like a related
talented person who was a bio piece of
[ __ ] like Brett Favre who stole a bunch
of [ __ ] welfare money from the state
of Mississippi to build his [ __ ]
daughters goddamn volleyball when he's
got millions of dollars that he could
have donated and put his own [ __ ]
name on it and not stole poor people's
money you piece of [ __ ] Brett Favre but
the dude can throw a football he's
talented he can throw a football
so we have to deal with vile pieces of
[ __ ] like that lizzo's not going around
stealing [ __ ] welfare money to build
her daughter a goddamn volleyball thing
when she could afford it if she's not
she's actually doing a service for
America to let America see this flute
for the first time in a long time over
200 years most people and including
Jenna Ellis here didn't even know what
[ __ ] existed
didn't even know it existed and frankly
lizzo did all of us a favor by these
boneheads being so triggered by it
because I don't even know if I would
have seen this I don't even know if I
would have seen this without these
people getting absolutely [ __ ]
triggered so keep going you [ __ ]
dummies keep going show us who you
really are let's finish up to see who
she really is you know she's like a
multi-millionaire and
um you know very famous but she gets on
stage in this really hideous outfit that
is wildly inappropriate and apparently
the is it like the Smithsonian or the
National Archives or something actually
allowed her to be the first person in
the United States history to play the
crystal Flute from James Madison I mean
this is just desecration purposefully of
America's history again it's more of
this racist [ __ ] how is it how I want to
know the if if
if I can get an actual answer from any
of these [ __ ] no you won't but yeah
people but I want to know how is this a
desecration
because she's black because she's black
that's why she's black and actually the
historic nature of this is that this
flute was it was from a time in this
country where lizzo would not even been
allowed to touch this flute right
because of her skin color you [ __ ]
boneheads I mean James Madison I don't
I'm pretty sure he didn't play in
instruments or didn't play the flute I
have no idea someone can correct me if
I'm wrong but this was a gift he got a
gift it's one I was like oh that's nice
it's a crystal flute I'm just gonna kind
of hold it and I'm not gonna play it
because I can't play it right
well yeah you don't want to break the
damn thing either well yeah yeah but
also it's like oh you get this oh cool
like this is a gift it means a lot you
got this thing can you play that
instrument maybe maybe not I'm pretty
sure James Madison didn't but
now there's an opportunity someone has
the talent to do so and they and they
did that with lizzo and you know it's
just like that's that's [ __ ]
bullsh Jenna Jenna please please simmer
down now okay girl you're about to have
a stroke because you're getting a little
too worked up over something that is not
is not
threatening you or anyone else
it has nothing to do with you it well
but it is a threat to their narrative
though it is a threat to their narrative
that and and that's exactly what she's
saying here is that it is a desecration
to a to American history for a black
woman to play a white man's flute and
that is a that is a when it when people
find that popular and amazing and
they're like holy [ __ ] this is [ __ ]
awesome and the crowd is cheering that
because it is [ __ ] cool as [ __ ]
especially the joke she makes in this
video about a wine glass
because it's clever but the thing is is
that's a threat to their narrative that
truly is a threat to their narrative
that lizzo shouldn't be a millionaire
because that's what she's saying when
she's like oh she's a millionaire and
she's super famous I'm jealous that
she's that and she shouldn't be that
that's what she's saying it's it's all
projection
they're saying she shouldn't be famous
because she's an artist and the reason
why is because she's black she's black
I don't give a [ __ ] what anyone says you
can come at me with all the the weight
thing and that lizzle has body
confidence and all that it's because
she's black
it's what it is let's finish up with
this
vile take
on such a historic moment and this just
shows how much the left is laughing at
American history and they want to put
somebody like lizzo up to be like oh
yeah now you've made history honey it's
disgusting it's depraved and I don't
care what anybody says that woman is
super unhealthy she is absolutely
um not a role model in any way shape or
form and she is not oppressed so Ryan
your thoughts on this story when I first
watched the video okay definitely don't
want to hear what the [ __ ] he has to say
yeah
it's just I I know it'll be more of the
Ben Shapiro Walsh type [ __ ] I mean it's
just gross to see someone to to try to
bash someone right be like hey look
you're talented and well they won't even
say that but they're like a talented
woman played a flute right that's that's
what it is a talented person a
classically trained floutist played a
gift to James Madison for a sec term
from a Parisian Craftsman okay that's
where this all comes from and they want
to get upset because they
didn't get to touch it put it in their
mouth whatever the [ __ ] weird desire
they have and they're upset
that that a black woman a talented
classically trained flowers was able to
play this flute in front of thousands of
people in millions really because it was
shared online
and and they're they're even getting it
shared even more which is right exactly
which is completely fine but it's it's
that it's it's that ability or or lack
of sensibility from them to say oh well
you know what the only thing that we can
really attack is the way that she looks
her appearance her her weight or what
you know it's like there are they don't
have actual talking points they go this
is just a desecration because This
Woman's overweight and she's playing
this thing that was by a racist white
slave owning guy oh my God like it's
right how dare you offend the slave
owners from the 18 from from the from
the early 1800s how dare you right yeah
well that's why today our our title our
our thumbnail was hatred right
underneath Jenna Ellis so and I'm sure
your support for lizzo and go watch
these videos spread them around show
them to your family and friends because
it's beautiful the one in the Rotunda
the intimate video I actually believe
that's a More Beautiful video than the
one where she's on stage I think it's I
think it's beautiful
right absolutely if to be in that
building and hear that like walking by
and like oh [ __ ] oh it would be
incredible it would be incredible and
what a great piece of history that lizzo
a black woman gets to play play uh one
of our founding fathers who was a slave
owners Crystal flute
um be the first one to actually play it
and do it so well that that is history
and that's what really pisses him off uh
he's boneheads speaking of boneheads
speaking of boneheads we gotta do bone
end of the week here we gotta get to it
we'd spend a little too much time on
lizzo triggering these right-wing morons
these right-wing boneheads speaking
right with boneheads we got plenty and
bone of the week so everyone stick
around don't go anywhere are we getting
bone into the week coming up right after
this break we'll see ya on the other
side
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
guess what it's Friday the second hour
you vote every single week for bone end
of the week
me and Gabe go through your vote you
vote you decide we break it down second
hour every Friday bonehead of the week
did you see that transition damn I'm
good
ah damn that's crazy God damn
we got some boneheads this week it's um
it almost was the same ones though but
let's do this almost we're it's almost
the same let's let's do this let's get
to the song Let's get to bonehead of the
week because we're running out of time
here
bonehead of the week stick around off to
the song bone end of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to this edition of bonehead of
the week thanks for sticking with us all
week it's Friday and you know what
Friday means every single Friday that's
bonehead a week on the Tony Michaels
podcast and if you're watching the
replay on the Midas touch Network every
single Friday Friday Friday we have bone
in the week what happens is is you go
vote on Twitter
at Tony Michaels pod or on YouTube on
our YouTube channel at Tony Michaels
podcast on YouTube you vote you decide
who is the bonehead of the week and then
we break it down every single week here
on the Tony Michaels podcast in the
second hour because we broadcast Gabe
every single weekday Monday through
Friday for two full hours so this is
what we do on Friday so if you're on the
Midas touch Network channel subscribe
right now don't forget to do that if
you're watching the replay and also you
can download every single episode on
Apple Spotify Google you can even
download
the boat end of the week in and of
itself just go search the Tony Michaels
podcast
subscribe follow us everywhere and don't
forget to vote every single Thursday for
bone of the week Gabe who are our
boneheads this week well this week we've
got the insurrectionist wife of Supreme
Court Justice Clarence Thomas Ginny
Thomas we've got the uh quote unquote
judge Eileen Cannon as I like to refer
to her lately and the governor Ron death
santis hmm death Satan was actually
Satan that's another I mean that's the
one that was trending many today names
he does he's an [ __ ] yeah he is an
[ __ ] well you know is that who we
should start with is Juan DeSantis is
that who we should start with here yeah
we could start with Ron I think Ron
DeSantis should go [ __ ] himself and if
you want to get some Rhonda Santos can
go [ __ ] himself merch just go to
store.dtonymichaels.com
this stuff is flying off the shelves and
everyone I
think really likes this this art that we
did so
um go pick up your Rhonda Santa's merch
but Ronda santis
he's dealing with several things here he
was being a bonehead before the
hurricane hit Florida of course right
and he's definitely going to be a
bonehead um in the lead up to it
um but
the one thing I want to say is that
when you expect and I said this all week
this is the third day I've said it if
you expect to vote for a governor who
during Hurricane Sandy while he was a
congressperson he was a congressman then
he was a representative of the State of
Florida
and he had the chance to vote on on
federally for hurricanes in New York and
New Jersey for Hurricane Sandy he voted
no
that in and of itself just that thing
should disqualify you
from being a governor anywhere and the
reason why is because
you are the one who actually allocates
those federal funds when they come to
your state and to be a person who would
vote against another state getting it
because oh there's Democrats that live
there
that disqualifies you because it only
says it only says your motives and your
motive is to only give the money to the
people you want to have it you're not
going to do what's right by yourself
which also doesn't include uh just
because the people you want to have it
that doesn't necessarily mean your
constituents or the people that you
voted for that's like I want to pick and
choose who I think should get the money
or who should get the aid or the the
FEMA assistance or what have you uh just
because they're Republican they say oh I
don't want to give it these blue areas
or these blue States or what have you I
want to give it to this red state but
within the red State it's also doesn't
mean that they're going to give it to
everyone who was one of the people that
they voted for constituents so this
whole pick and choose uh I can have it
but you can have it this hypocrisy like
it's again it's the same old thing that
Republicans do every single day and
every time there's a tragedy or some
event where where that state or that
county or city or whatever it is that's
run by a Republican and they say oh [ __ ]
we actually need big government to come
in we need help
from our Collective Federal family as
I'll call it
they'll take it then they'll accept a
socialist well they'll accept the tax
money that goes into the pot and to have
that pot come back over to them when
they really need it but if someone else
needs it they go
[ __ ] yourself not a thing well he's Kosh
he's cautiously optimistic that the
president United States Joe Biden will
do what he's supposed to which Joe Biden
sprung in the action immediately yeah he
didn't even hesitate the administration
didn't even hesitate here and so he's
like there was a forecast of a hurricane
you mean we spend federal dollars to
know that [ __ ] are you kidding me it's
crazy it's crazy that sounds like
socialism Gabe we shouldn't be engaging
in any of that I mean it is forecasting
forecasting that seems that seems a
little a little communist God forbid
Tony that we actually use science right
to forecast uh well there's another bad
disaster there's another bad word you
and your bad words
but God forbid we use science and
technology to actually forecast and
predict the pattern and the actual uh
path that something like hurricane or
Ian will take and then say okay will we
know where to uh send resources we know
where to have people ready to go to put
the lines back up you know we know where
to make sure to set up our camps with
FEMA to make sure that it's out of the
path and it doesn't you know doesn't get
lost to the hurricane and we're able to
have a safe secure location where people
can go to actually get Aid to get food
to get water to get shelter right
almost kind of sounds Christian like in
the values whoa whoa whoa easy easy no
no no don't don't do that either now
you're now you're really you're really
getting no I'm just saying well let's
let's listen to Tucker Carlson here I
mean Tucker Carlson
um talk to Ron DeSantis uh about how
he's cautiously optimistic about the
fact that Joe Biden is already sprung
into action here I don't know what he's
talking about but let's listen
when a natural disaster like this
strikes the state it is it is common
it's I I think it's always the case that
the state receives federal aid given how
politicized things are at the moment are
you confident you're going to get the
federal support Florida needs
so I actually spoke with the president
and he said he wants to be helpful so we
did submit a request for reimbursement
for the next 60 days at 100 percent uh
that's uh significant uh support but
it's a significant storm so we haven't
heard back from it but I'm actually
cautiously optimistic that we do I mean
as you say tucker we live in a very
politicized time but you know when
people are fighting for their lives when
their whole livelihood is at stake when
they've lost everything if you can't put
politics aside for that uh then you're
just not going to be able to so I'll
work with anybody who wants to help the
people of Southwest Florida and
throughout our state
so there you have it
yeah we talked about this yesterday and
I'll repeat my point there is no reason
whatsoever for Ron DeSantis to say well
we submitted our expenses and we are
going to or we we believe we will be
reimbursed for the 60 days up to 100
like
there's no reason
to to try to passively uh passive
aggressively kind of throw Biden and the
federal government under the bus when
they were literally and are still
sending resources and funding to make
sure that Florida has what it needs
to keep everyone safe right to get
people to Safe shelter and to get them
resources that they need but but the
whole fact of Ron DeSantis right now
he's trying to make a dig at one already
had a conversation with Biden and Biden
was like yeah I got you no problem don't
really care if you're red I just care
that you're an American because that's
my job as a president it's the United
States it's a United States exactly I
mean like Obama said we're not a red
we're not a blue we're the United States
of America and and that is something
that Joe Biden definitely brings the
table especially when there is a
catastrophic hurricane coming through
Florida and we want to make sure that
people are safe right well here is here
is Joe Biden uh at FEMA let's see it's
this is a small clip let's see what he
had to say how would you describe your
relationship and your conversation with
Governor DeSantis it's totally
irrelevant but I'll answer it okay in
fact very fine he complied me he thanked
me for the immediate response we had he
told me how much he appreciated it said
he was extremely happy with what's going
on this is not about whether or anything
having to do with our disagreements
politically this is about saving
people's lives homes and businesses
that's what this is about and so I've
been I've talked to him four or five
times already and it's not a matter of
my disagreements with them on other
items
uh you want a lesson on how to be a
leader there it is there it is and again
I expected nothing more or less from Joe
Biden than to
reached the bar of human decency
patriotism being an American caring
about people that are in the state of
Florida because they're here and he's
the president United States like just
that low bar they are so [ __ ] they we
watched as Donald Trump [ __ ] during the
pandemic tried to [ __ ] on states that he
thought were blue and democrat-run
states and all this nonsense during a
[ __ ] pandemic where millions of
people were dying right he tried to [ __ ]
all over him he's like oh you guys get
some stuff right Jared Kushner was part
of the team that was like oh well we're
all going to choose which states there
the Democrat or Republican that are
great resources they weren't even saying
it out loud they were literally saying
it out loud in front of each other and
here Joe Biden is like look I don't give
a damn rather Rhonda Santos is a
Republican or he's a [ __ ] up Joe Biden
no knows that Rhonda Santos is the
governor of Florida that is what he has
to do he has to work with the governor
of Florida to get them federal aid so
that Governor can then give that Aid to
his State like businesses citizens
property to clean up I mean Joe Biden
understands this and one reason why Gabe
and they they always knock him for this
and I don't really get this they're like
oh he's he was in government for so many
years he knows how it works like okay so
why why is that a bad thing is it's a
bad thing that Joe Biden understands how
disaster relief Works in this moment you
people are boned it and the other thing
too I want to point about this clip
is when Joe Biden says yay call me thank
me he said thanks a lot and he I had
four or five conversations with him
right I I don't begrudge the guy because
he's looking for federal money for his
State he's trying to help his
constituents I want to do the same thing
is to help the people of Florida and
really it shits it shits all over the
idea that Ron DeSantis played on on
Tucker Carlson where he's like you know
he dances around why I had to talk to
the President right right I didn't have
a choice but to talk to the President
right when it is that is the case the
president United States Joe Biden
doesn't have a choice but to talk to the
governor of Florida here and and vice
versa but the absolute projection of
Rhonda Santos and Tucker Carlson there
is telling is telling and when you have
Joe Biden like of course this is what
they were going to do this is what the
federal government does I'm standing at
FEMA I'm standing at FEMA who is He is
wanting money from and I am not gonna
try to keep him from getting it I'm
gonna try to give him every [ __ ]
penny I possibly can give him it's it's
it's
the core of it is it's not political
it's just being an empathetic caring
human
that's what it is meanwhile Tucker
Carlson bull a lot of things have been
politicized these days
a a point just like Joe Biden is like
that's irrelevant there's no reason why
my relationship with him doesn't [ __ ]
matter what I care about is that he has
the funds and the resources to make sure
that he protects the Floridians that are
going through this right this natural
disaster that's that's it that's the
basic that's the bare minimum let me
help you help those in your state and
there should be no politics because
there is no politics around it it's just
again being a human who cares about
other humans novel idea I know I know
novel weird stuff okay who else do we
have on the list we have uh Jeannie
Thomas the insurrectionist no what
happened serial killer sociopath Ginny
Thomas with that crazy smile that she
gave yesterday yeah we played the video
yesterday should we replay the video of
her walking in is that the one we should
replay is there a video of her saying
that um of course she believes that the
election was stolen and why was the
video that came out I think that was the
I think I know I know
like people people talking afterwards
okay well here's here apparently seems
to be a picture oh that's the wrong one
but that seems to be a picture Genie
Clarence Thomas
um
oh my god
oh she's election denier and um the smug
look on her face in this video and the
absolute smartassery in this video like
I'm better than you and I won't be held
accountable type attitude then just
watch you'll see
Miss Thomas why do you feel like you
need to speak to the committee to clear
your name
in here could you speak with your
husband if your beliefs of the election
being stolen
thank you for your question I look
forward to answering members
there is nothing creepier than somebody
smiling and very quietly speaking this
isn't like an ASMR video kind of thing
she's like thank you for asking your
question thank you thank you for being
here for being here it's like it's so
glad you're here here it is it is super
creepy super creepy almost like she's a
robot in a skin suit or something right
I have no idea I mean it's just like is
this like
um the original version of Jared Kushner
like he's an upgrade or some [ __ ] I mean
this is weird the other thing that I
didn't notice till just now she has a
cane did you notice that yeah well I
didn't see it but I heard that right I
didn't know I didn't notice it the other
day when I want because I watched this
several times trying to figure out like
who these people were and what because
it was hard to even kind of determine
what she says because the last line she
says is I am looking forward to
answering that question
never is what I think she says I'm
looking forward to answering
I look forward to overthrowing the
government
like I I look forward to skinning you
alive later like that is that's the vibe
I get it's a Dahmer bike oh yeah huge
Dom revive well
it's not surprising that Jeannie Thomas
after she went and talked not under oath
to the January 6 uh committee she came
out and I guess it was an interview or
something where she said no I totally
believe that the election was stolen
like she even even the act of her going
in to try to clear her and her husband's
name in front of the select committee
didn't convince her that she possibly
should say in public but here's the
thing
my guess is
she has to keep this facade up because
if Jeannie Thomas went out in public and
said of course Donald Trump lost of
course Joe Biden it was all [ __ ]
right Donald Trump would turn on her in
a minute would turn on her in a minute
and they just can't afford that they
just can't afford that because what if
that Messiah becomes king again he might
just save them so they can't they can't
turn on him yet
um in public at least in private like
Bill Barr did and several others now
Bill Barr did it in private with the
select committee and then they played
this [ __ ] out loud and Trump turned on
him and Bill Barr's like okay well if
that's what you're gonna do I'm gonna
roast you on this documents thing so
speaking speaking of the documents
oh man we got some documents yeah we
were gonna make Donald Trump one of the
contestants right in that right but it
would have been the same slate is that
right it would have been the same one as
last week that's crazy because last week
it was Ron DeSantis was on for uh
trafficking uh humans Venezuelan
migrants to uh Martha's Vineyard right
Eileen Cannon again doubling down and
saying that uh Trump should not have to
do what he has to do which is he broke
the law and has to face the consequences
and then also uh Donald Trump we had on
there because I think just related to
the documents itself hey well I mean
he's he's just like world-class
bone-headedry I mean it's just it
doesn't stop right like he just he won't
quit he won't quit the moan headedry so
he ended up being the dishonorable
mention because we wanted to give
someone else a shot and that's why we
threw Genie Thomas she didn't have a
chance though no against some these
other uh honestly you know I said it I
tweeted out this morning I said judge
again in quotes quote-unquote judge
judge Eileen Cannon wanted to be famous
but now she's Infamous
oh she is an Infamous bonehead but the
reason why I think we put Donald Trump
on here is because a video we played the
other day where he's in his office
uh-huh I think so while hurricane Ian is
taking place I actually had a there are
a couple uh Publications course he's on
the other side of the state right he's
on the unfortunately or unfortunately
however you know he's on the other
estate and you know the path kind of
goes goes through it doesn't really hit
uh the area of Palm Beach Mar-A-Lago
he's fine Ian missed the assignment
really honestly he's like you know
whatever oops Yeah
uh I shared a video online that actually
picked up a lot of steam and it was
found its way on different like
Publications which I was really
surprised about but it's the it's the
the lack of
or rally it's just a tone deaf response
while a natural disaster is happening in
the very state
that you're making this video from while
people are suffering losing their homes
people are dying he decides the best use
of his time is not to say hey
let's raise money
on behalf of those who are who are
victims of this hurricane
instead he says Ah you guys I got this
really important deadline happening at
the end of September to make sure that
my quarter three financials don't look
like dog [ __ ] because the August did
well how much did he raise in August how
much money because it had to be a lot of
money in terms of just not compared to
what we would think no no it was it was
the number that he raised in the month
of August is four
zero forty thousand four forty forty
forty million just just forty forty
dollars
forty dollars wait wait so like one zero
did Eric did Eric give forty dollars to
get his dad's attention you know that is
hard I've read through the financial
statements for the last few months of
his Super Pac and I I can't identify hmm
for donors were obviously super weird it
almost feels like they can't charge
credit cards or something like they're
yeah they're they don't have their
credit card machine to process cards
here
here's a whistle lips here
um giving his little he's begging for
money let's let's watch we have a
baby oh you do and there's no
there's never ever nobody has never been
so disrespected our country has never
been so low certainly in the minds of
others and who especially the leaders of
other countries what lead I know over
the world we have to change it we have
to bring our country back we made
America great and now we're going to
have to make America great again you
sure this ain't from 2016.
you can do help out we have to meet the
deadline the midterms are coming up it's
going to be one of the most important
elections in the history of our country
so I hope you can help out and help out
we really appreciate it and good luck
so he's saying here that we you should
help with the midterms by not giving to
the candidates but giving to his
personal slush fund is it yeah when I'm
taking it yeah and and here's the thing
little to no money has been given to any
of these candidates running in the
midterms so he's trying to uh he's
piggybacking on the midterms are
approaching so he's like we gotta get
this money in now we got to get this
money in for the midterms but really the
money is being used to pay off his legal
bills well I mean I'm not saying that
you know I'm not for this I mean if
they're going to give money to someone
I'd rather they give money to spend on
his legal defense where he's going to
lose than a candidate that could win I'm
just saying I'm just saying then that's
why Donald Trump got dishonorable
mention because he's [ __ ] broke he
can't even squeeze together 50 bucks
holy [ __ ] he can't even squeeze together
50 bucks what happened with our Alpha
guck here Jordan Peterson was training
this morning on Twitter what do we got
here
The in-cell King The King found his way
on um he looks like a Pierce Morgan here
doesn't he
say again he does look like an incel
King here doesn't he yeah I mean under
the tears of the incel king will he was
crying
he was crying he was crying
I was gonna try to cut it I was supposed
to try to get deep but but do you have
the YouTube clip in the in the time
stamp right yeah yeah I got that yeah
I'll get that so basically the context
here is that Jordan Peterson went on to
Pierce Morgan uncensored or whatever the
new show is oh another in silk in
another and sell Lord Pierce Morgan
uncensored so uh is this the same show
where he interviewed Donald Trump and
they were like trying to you know oh
yeah they were you know patting each
other on the back and then Pierce Morgan
challenged him on one question Donald
Trump he was got up like a crybaby and
left because he couldn't handle is that
the same show I believe that's the
second show okay that's after he that's
after he left the uh
the
um the good morning right right in
Britain okay yeah yeah uh advertised
so this is the clip where uh the
question is basically Olivia Wilde and
he'll give context but Olivia Wilde says
that Jordan Peterson is the leader of
the incels right what's my time what's
my time stamp here yeah it's the full
clip
oh okay it leads into it I mean he kind
of goes on afterward but after he starts
crying okay I thought that there was a I
thought there was a time stamp here oh
that was the longer one from the spot
okay okay so there's a full version but
this is the the abbreviated version
let's listen
I've got to wrap it up I don't want to
but I have to I want to ask you just
quickly uh the film director Olivia
Wilde has a new movie out which she says
it's based on you this insane man this
pseudo-intellectual hero to the in-cell
community in cell being these weirdo
loner men yeah uh who are despicable in
many ways is that you are you the
intellectual Heroes of these people
foreign
okay it really is Rich to watch Pierce
Morgan call in cells like as if he
doesn't know that a [ __ ] ton of his
little his little following is a bunch
of these [ __ ] incels like these Elon
stands even oh my God come on come on
Pierce and then you ask him are you that
because I thought I was that are you is
it you or is it me I can't I can't
remember
why not you know
um
people have been after me for a long
time by because I've been speaking to
disaffected young men you know what a
terrible thing to do that is oh my God
foreign
[Applause]
oh my god listen listen I'm a white dude
I'm a white dude in America I'm not
marginalized no one has ever repressed
me it's it's not a thing Jordan Peterson
not a [ __ ] especially someone who
comes off as an elitist intellectual
right who goes
I believe I mean Canadian he's not even
American he's Canadian I believe he's
gonna and I'm not trying to toss stones
at Canada I'm just saying that he's not
a a Canadian he's not he's not even
beautiful psychologist and he's he's
more popular in America than he is up
there because they don't really play
that nonsense up there right but this
idea that the [ __ ] [ __ ] white
dudes a bunch of white dudes in this
country are oppressed and [ __ ] and
they're the marginalized can you get the
[ __ ] out of here oh my God you're
pointing out you're pointing out white
people's privilege how dare you oppress
them get the [ __ ] out of here
this is the same guy who also and I
think I can find a clip here well I
wanna I wanna I wanna play him crying
here I gotta believe I want to watch him
cry let's let's watch him cry
it's making you emotional talk about it
well God you know
oh God you know very difficult to
understand
many young men are in that category
um
casual
insults these these in cells is what
does it mean it's like well these men
they're they don't know how to make
themselves attractive to women who are
very picky and good for them women like
be picky that's that's your gift okay
I'm not gonna let him dig it yeah pull
any deeper than he's got it here the
reason why these people think this way
is because of Jordan Peterson and people
like him the reason why white trumped up
white dudes think they're marginalized
and oppressed is because of people like
Jordan Peterson
they [ __ ] brainwashed them into
thinking that equality
to the oppressor is oppression this is
all bone-headedry it's it's just dumb
[ __ ] and it's laughable on its face
it's really ridiculous is there another
clip you want to show this I want to
show a clip it's just to give people
full time
yeah yeah oh man perfect that was not
the first time he's ever cried but the
clip that I just sent you will give
people context for anyone who doesn't
know who Jordan Peterson is because
yeah if this wasn't a take to say wow
that gives me an idea of who he is it's
definitely gonna be this next take where
Jordan Peterson is on Joe Rogan and
talks about
black skin color and now he's not right
here's another lord of the incels uh Joe
Rogan and it's the same [ __ ] these
people wouldn't think they're
marginalized it wouldn't be crying about
their oppression that doesn't exist
right if it weren't for [ __ ] like this
let's listen depending on who you ask
either you're a voice of reason and
rationality and
and uh you know a personal
responsibility or he couldn't even
hardly get it out did you notice that he
couldn't even hardly come up with the
words yeah what is it called what what
is this weird thing okay or you're a
voice of intolerance and bigotry and
anger and hateful sexual oppressions
mean every white man yeah and and a mean
angry white man hilarious exactly and I
mean at all that's what's dumb about
that statement it's you're not mean at
all I am white actually that's a lie too
I'm kind of tan and he was actually not
bad
oh [ __ ] I'm darker than you yeah it's
ridiculous yeah but neither of us are
white well I'm Italian and he was brown
not black well isn't that weird yeah
it's really weird black and white thing
is so strange because the shades are tan
and brown there's such a spectrum of
shades of people okay I can't I can't I
can't I can't it's we've done this video
but before I think we've done this video
two or three times because these [ __ ]
bones just I mean it's a video that will
never get an old and it will always show
you who these people are right
specifically Jordan Peterson trying to
make some claim that I'm not actually
white uh he's he's not he's saying he's
brown like what he's saying is I'm
oppressed because of my skin colors he's
like hey I've already know about
nobody I'm not as white as my shirt
which is kind of like this weird
off-white but he's like I'm I'm not
white guys so like I'm not the bully and
I'm not the villain here I'm actually an
off-white I'm like an eggshell white I'm
like a white that you might go to Home
Depot and say I don't really want fresh
egg color right but I want like a hint
of some color in there just to show
people that I'm not actually this do you
think he did the 23 and me and he is
just pure white yeah I think when you're
white and there's no people usually
people like they have something like
sub-Saharan African right this and this
and it's just like 100 percent
no no no way to doubt it just white
is wider than the than the powder that
goes up Donald Trump Junior's nose we
couldn't even tell you if you're British
Irish Scottish like anything over there
you're like we couldn't even tell if you
were like from from any you're like uh
you know oh your heritage is the Vikings
are
um which
oh man I gotta finish up here on this
bonehead of the week I hate to get off
Jordan Peterson though but but we got to
go to another bonehead
who thinks she has privilege here um her
name is Judge Eileen Cannon everyone
famously are infamously as you said
earlier knows her now as the judge who
has really shitty legal takes this is
very awkward for a federal judge who is
supposed to know what they're doing Gabe
it's really awkward it's really strange
to watch a federal judge not know
anything about uh Federal judging at all
you know the rule of law their job
because here's what happened real in
because
um I don't even know if we don't have
video over because she won't even allow
video or anything in her courtroom right
because she didn't want people to see
what she's doing so here's the thing
Trump asked for a special Master which
is boneheaded in and of itself
he decides that that's a good idea then
Trump recommends judge Deary in the
eastern district of New York who is kind
of a no-nonsense judge who is on the
fisa court that issued the warrant and
the the the wiretapping of Carter page
who was part of the Trump campaign in
2016 and the right wing hates that
Outlook it's corruption
and the doj says oh you're going to
recommend that judge we'll take him
we'll make him the special master that
sounds great
judge Eileen Cannon says fantastic I'm
gonna appoint him as the special Master
Deary does the thing that Eileen Cannon
should have done when the Motions
entered her Court When Donald Trump
wanted a special Master she should have
said you were making all these claims
are these claims true that's what that's
the bare minimum and judge Deary was
kind of doing her job through the
special Master position now Donald
Trump's team did not like that because
they want to be able to lie in public
that is that is what they're doing this
has nothing to do with the criminal case
this has nothing to do with the criminal
investigation the doj is not going to
stop their criminal Vision investigation
or stop a grand jury from indicting him
this special Master thing is all
distraction and all nonsense it's all
delay tactics but the thing that Trump's
lawyers know and that Eileen Cannon
knows is that if if Trump does what
diary wants him to do is Trump can't
then go out and public looking say the
opposite of what they filed in court now
Trump can he'll [ __ ] lie no matter
what but when I say Trump I mean his
team his defense his defense here his
legal team if they file in court in a
motion with a special master that no
that planet evidence thing that's a lie
there's no Planet evidence he did not
declassify these things they cannot
claim that in court they know it she
knows it he knows it Grandpa Poopypants
knows it that Deary is really
challenging any defense he has here
because it's not a defense it's not one
planted evidence that wasn't planted is
not a defense I Declassified with my
[ __ ] Big Mac stained hands or my mind
is not a defense yeah they're my
documents not the government's documents
is not an offense because it's not real
it's all wise so it's not offense so
judge Eileen Cannon here decides what
she's gonna do is now become the special
master
and do and tell the special Master you
can't do that because that's oppression
towards you know marginalized white men
especially Rich billionaires who grew up
with a silver spoon who've never been
hell accountable for anything in their
entire life you just can't do that yeah
that's when I am I am I way off here is
that the story here no I mean basically
uh Eileen Cannon became Trump's defense
attorney like that's what's happening
right when she's given the opportunity
then she will say oh well we need to
protect no he doesn't have to say these
things or commit these things under oath
because that would cause I don't know
perjury right be lying right it would go
against him and you know like well again
I think I think it takes aim at the
lawyers more than it does Trump because
Trump he doesn't give a [ __ ] the lawyers
have to acknowledge like look
there's the there's a
there's the phrase Maca right which has
now been associated with make attorneys
get attorneys and this is especially
true right now because now what Trump is
doing is he's making these attorneys
he's putting them in a position
to say
okay you guys you guys know what
happened and you have to lie for it
which would then violate what they have
you know made a a promise to when they
were accepted when they were given their
their law license to actually practice
law
so
they're they're getting in a very
interesting position too like Trump can
lie sure whatever but now these lawyers
are are putting their own careers at
risk because they would then be also
lying right under oath
and uh under the under this
investigation to say oh yeah well you
know well several of them have backed
away because there's like there's no way
I'm gonna get caught up in this idea
that I'm gonna lose my wealth my way of
life my well-being because you want me
to lie for you on a court motion you're
a dumbass no way and that's what is
happening with Deering that's where
Eileen Cannon has done the bone edit
Thing by covering for Trump and his
legal team because they can't cover
their own ass because he's in hot water
here he's in deep [ __ ] and she knows it
dearie knows it the legal team knows it
Trump knows it because he knows what he
did right and it's criminal I mean
what's gonna happen is the same thing
that happened with the 100 100
classified documents right you were
going to say oh okay fine we'll appeal
this decision and then it goes to the
court and the court says yeah you're
[ __ ] idiot why would you even say
that right and then what happened last
time was she said nope he gets to keep
these documents so they held him off
then they went to the uh the ninth
circuit or the 11th circuit and they
said oh you're an idiot right now you
can have these documents and then she
was like okay you guys are right and now
she's come back to say okay cool I'm
gonna make sure that you know and then
she goes forward with what she what
she's done right now which is around
making certain statements or not having
to and pushing the pushing the the the
the case out further till December I
think so is your prediction hearing that
uh if this because from my understanding
I'm not a lawyer everyone should go
listen to Ben Marcellus on this more
than me uh but um from Midas Touch you
can get it here on the Midas touch
network if you're watching the replay of
bone end of the week
um analysis of every single motion but I
I believe that that emotion kind of that
doj has to kind of wait for something to
file a motion to appeal to the um the
11th circuit but it likely will be
overturned but here's the thing about
the criminal case this this special
Master nonsense has nothing to do with
the criminal investigation right not a
goddamn thing the only thing that this
is is that dispute here is what
documents are what and the fact of the
matter is the Department of Justice has
already done this work has already done
this work and Deary knows that that's
why he's asking these questions to get
them to just adhere to facts inside of a
courtroom that's all he's trying to
adjust to get them to do the legal team
to adhere to facts so that they can
frame up a factual defense which they do
not have that's the main thing here and
Eileen Cannon knows it and that's what
made her to bonehead of the week my
prediction was not her but you guys
voted for her and that's what happens in
democracy you lean into it you vote you
decide we break it down let's give
Eileen judge quote unquote Eileen Gannon
her moment of boneheadness
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you judge Eileen Gannon for being
an hour
our winner of Bonet of the week you
certainly are boneheaded I would bet
that this is not the last time she's
gonna show up on this no I'm telling you
once this is the once they file this
it's gonna get appealed it's gonna go to
the 11th circuit she's gonna be back on
bone net of the week and they're gonna
be like is she gonna be three weeks in a
row is she gonna be three weeks in a row
holy [ __ ] next week that'll be three
three weeks in a row damn right now
she's heating up that's right that's
right next week she's on fire dude
that's right she's on fire so every
Friday don't forget to come watch the
Tony Michaels podcast watch bonehead
live in the second hour and also watch
on the replay on Midas Touch network if
you're on Midas Touch Network right now
subscribe to the minus touch Network and
don't forget to go over the Tony
Michaels podcast YouTube channel And
subscribe there help us out give us some
Support also follow us on at Tony
Michaels pod because you can vote for
bone end of the week on Twitter and
YouTube you vote you decide we break it
down every single week
what a bone end of the week it did not
go the way I thought it was gonna go but
you know that's just how it works the
votes fall we certify them we present
them to the public
here no trying to influence the uh the
voting that's happening like Jenny
Thomas no stop we play fair we let you
guys decide that's right bonehead of the
week thank you everyone for joining us
if you're on the Tony Michaels podcast
stick around we got some announcements
after the song if you're on the minus
touch Network join us next week on
bonehead of the week foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
of the week
I I'm in love with that segment it's
great I love it she is such a dumbass
oh my God damn [ __ ] how could
you be so goddamn stupid I I mean it
does question how can you it's pretty
easy obviously it it does it does call
in a question like
has there been money slipped underneath
the table or something I mean this is
getting ridiculous I don't know I mean
she this is getting ridiculous from what
I remember I think it was she's 20
months she's been not that long she
probably won't be a federal judge very
long after after this no not uh she just
won't have the confidence
it's not been that long because she was
she was uh confirmed right before he
um right before he was voted out right
and left office and this took just over
20 months as a federal judge because it
takes a while to get him actually in the
judgeship you know like get in their
position get them sworn in as the
federal judge get them on the bench and
get them get them that casework in there
in their uh queue
um
Hellboy oh boy what a week of news it's
been great and I want to say again
anyone in Florida
um please please be safe uh I know
there's still some people that they're
looking for and there's still some
people missing because
um unfortunately there's going to be a
death toll out of Florida unfortunately
so anyone in Florida please be safe and
um
yeah help out your your fellow Americans
no matter who or where they are
um and and just just give your support
in any single way you can down there in
Florida and understand that when we go
after Ron DeSantis it is because he is
an absolute scumbag and he has given me
no proof and until he does
um I will not believe anything that
comes out of his mouth and he can go
[ __ ] himself just like the shirts say
Rhonda santis can go [ __ ] himself I I
just I can't bring myself to act like
he's not a scumbag Gabe I just can't
well I mean I just can't you look at all
the times that he's been on video right
he's got his police force behind him he
berates a kid because he's wearing a
mask again your body your choice but
right because he's making a public
statement in front of people he can't
have that image of people wearing a mask
in the State of Florida because they
beat covet right they beat covet sure
okay you know then you find out you know
like the guy you know manipulates data
when it comes to the covet numbers like
that came out with the Whistleblower so
there
and even with disaster relief the guy
has proven that he is unqualified to
even be anywhere near disaster relief
when he voted against it because it was
Coastal elitist that is a disqualifier
right there everyone come back next week
it's been a it's been a hell of a week
for news uh we know I want to give all
the audience here I don't think we're
gonna get a January 6 hearing next week
that is the word uh publicly it seems
that way even some of our private
conversations that we have with people
that are trying to organize this thing
it doesn't look like we're gonna get a
hearing next week it looks like we will
hear what the schedule is though I think
Benny Thompson either over the weekend
or the very part of next week is going
to give us win that next January 6th
select hearing is so make sure to stay
tuned go follow us on Twitter at Tony
Michaels pod make sure you follow us on
Facebook as well at the Tony Michaels
download every single episode Monday
through Friday and also bonehead the
week on the weekends and also sub here
on the YouTube channel it's very
important because as soon as these
hearings come down the bike we are going
to let you know we are going to let you
know because we run on your support here
and that's how we do it Tony Michaels
dot live slash tip Tony Michaels dot
live slash tip and go give a one-time
tip and give a monthly tip set up
monthly we run on your support not just
monetary support but your actual support
watching listening downloading
and also the merch oh my God this one is
flying off the shelves Dirk Brandon
store.d Tony michaels.com and you know
what the one of the most popular bro uh
dark Brandon
um merch items is the coffee mug oh
that's one of your own day with the
little dark Brandon right a little dark
brand I don't know why if you put do you
put sugar in your dark Brandon milk
creamer I don't know what you're putting
your Darkness light roasted dark roast I
don't know these things because I don't
drink coffee but I support anyone yeah
you don't drink much he does the
streaming
man
well you can put the nice part is about
the dark Brandon Gap is you can put your
streamed your bubbly water in the dark
Brandon in the dark random gift so go
get your dark Brandon coffee mugs at
store that the Tony michaels.com show
your support for the show here and we
appreciate everything everyone have a
great and safe weekend no matter where
you're at especially if you're in the uh
half of this storm be safe be healthy
and lean into your democracy until next
week Surf's Up [ __ ] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon